مواكب لده ما كتبه توفير حكيم لما كان
بيكتب في الاهرام رساله مع الله فهو قال
له لا لا الى الله مش مع الله يعني يعني
بدات الشعراوي كمان كان داخل في معارك مع
توفيق الحكيم اساسا طبعا مع دكتور يوسف
ادريس مع الدكتور زكي نجيب محمود اه
الفيلسوف حتى احمد بهاء الدين يعني عايز
اقول لم يكن بس دكتور فؤاد زكريا لكن لا
ده كان داخل مصر كان في كتاب كبار وقامات
كبيره
داخله ماذا اخذوا عليه ابرز ما اخذ هؤلاء
المفكرين دائما انتقدهم لافكاره انها
بالنسبه لهم افكار رجعيه
بتودينا خطوات للخلف الضر بدل ما تقدمنا
للامام طبعا لو لم يكن الشيخ الشعراوي
يتمتع بكل تلك الكاريزما وكل هذه
الجماهريه ما كانش رد الفعل بقيت بقى
بالقوه دي بس هو لانه الشعراوي يجب ان
نعترف لانه الشعراوي كان لما بيقول حاجه
في التليفزيون في ظل كمان لازم نقول لازم
نقول للناس انه في التليفزيون الارضي كانت
الرساله اللي بتطلع من الدوله قويه جدا
لان كل البلد يعني بتتفرج عليها